i'm steve and you may not know kieran
he's part of the link team and you can't
see sam but he's the cameraman
and uh we're going to
try to answer some of the questions that
you've sent us on our 90-day challenge
and i hope that you are all working hard
on the 90-day challenge
and so we gathered some of the questions
there were a lot of questions some of
them i've kind of grouped them together
we've grouped them together and we
thought it would be interesting if we
kind of had a question and answer so
karen's going to ask and
by the way karen's working on spanish
and so is sam
what were some of the questions okay so
the first one here uh
was uh how do you learn vocabulary so
you don't get overwhelmed and forget the
original vocabulary that you learned
okay first of all you do forget the
vocabulary that you learned that's a
given in fact it's good to forget the
vocabulary if you forget it and relearn
it and forget it again and relearn it
that's how you're going to retain it so
i read and listen
and of course the first time i come
across a new word i link it it's now
converted to yellow and then i'll see it
again and i not only do i forget the
meaning i forget that i ever saw the
word before and so it's this process of
engaging with the content forgetting
relearning forgetting and that's how you
learn so that's really not a problem
that's
yeah that's how i see that all right so
the second one is
where do you find really good starting
content for polish
japanese mandarin german and korean okay
these were obviously five different
questions that i received it started
with polish a number of polish people
told me that i shouldn't do this mandel
gadanski that it's a 19th century novel
and it's not very good and i must admit
it was very difficult so i was happy to
get off that
i discovered in our library we had some
content from real polish and i started
doing that and the material areas is
phenomenal and i've been in touch with
pyotr and i will talk more about that in
my next video
but japanese mandarin german korean i
mean
you know i'm not studying i'm studying
korean right now everyone has to look
you have to look for your own content
things that are you know of interest to
you i can't give you any answers uh
korean i searched some podcasts which i
had uh you know transcribed
part of language learning is being an
explorer and you have to find your own
resources so i other than that you can
come on link we have content in our
library audio and text
and you can use those they're available
for free download if you don't use all
of the link functionality which of
course i recommend you do it's more
effective
and you can ask on our forum but you've
got to look for it sorry no that's good
so the third question is um we actually
have a course on link called who is she
right which is in polish
um so one of the users was asking is how
did you do the who is she course without
any grammar
and uh
do we learn grammar when we have very
few words right so there were two
questions there
uh okay obviously when i'm doing polish
i've already done russian czech
ukrainian so i have a sense of how you
know slavic languages word in terms of
the grammar i'm not too fussed about how
the endings in polish are different from
the endings in czech or russian it
doesn't matter it doesn't prevent me
from understanding what i'm listening to
so there'll be words that i don't know i
look up those words and the grammar
doesn't bother me at some point i will
go back in there and try to nail down
better you know the specific uh you know
polish endings but for the time being it
doesn't prevent me from understanding
the story
and this other person asked me in fact
he was studying slovak and he said he
only had a few hundred words and he
can't remember the grammar of course you
can't remember the grammar i think
someone else said he has trouble with
the endings in german don't sweat it as
piotr of real polish says we learn
subconsciously and so you have to expose
yourself to the language and if you
learn it subconsciously by experiencing
it you will have a much better grasp of
the language than if you try to remember
rules and pretty soon there's so many
rules and exceptions you
forget the rules and stuff right learn
it through gradually exposing yourself
to it and don't worry about the grammar
until you're so curious about the
grammar you go back in you look it up
and then it starts to you know stick
yeah that's a great point okay uh next
question do you use music to learn
languages
people often people ask me that the
answer is no
first of all not the music i presume
they mean the words of songs right if
you are like the key
in language learning is content content
is king if you're interested in songs
that's a great way to learn because then
you start singing the songs and so but i
just am not that interested i'm
interested in other things so whatever
you're interested in go for it content
is king or queen
okay
um next question what is your daily
language learning routine and how much
time does one need to spend a day
learning a language you know there is no
rule i think if you're serious you
should spend an hour a day
at least and but there's no upper limit
and and that's what i do but 70 of that
is listening because i can listen in my
car i can listen while preparing
breakfast i can listen all kinds of you
know different places so listening is 75
of it uh i don't really have a routine
again i like to do what i feel like
doing so
i might get on my i have a separate home
i get on with my ipad and i read through
an uh uh you know a lesson in in i link
on my ipad uh then if i follow after the
stepper i might lift a few weights then
i'll be listing while i'm doing that
okay uh so it all adds up i grab some
time here sometime there there is no
routine
all right
and what do you do when you're
demotivated or not interested or you're
not feeling like you're getting any
anywhere making any progress you know
there were a number of questions like
this
one person said you know i've been
living in spain and i'm not motivated
and my spanish is no good and another
person said uh
yeah a japanese i know a number of
people had this problem
first of all
don't tell yourself that you're not
doing well
okay that's a bad message
whatever you're able to do in the
language is good because that's better
than zero right so you are lots of
people are just unilingual so if you
have some knowledge of the language
you're able to say a few things you're
already good but you'd like to get
better all right
here again in my experience the key is
content do stuff that is interesting and
enjoyable if you like songs go for songs
if you like movies go for movies
i must say i in my polish as i said i
started into this uh mandel gadanski it
was very difficult very dry a little
discouraging and then i discovered pyotr
stuff and it just opened up this
tremendous door for me so you've got to
find and i can't tell you what's good
for you you've got to find the content
that turns you on and then
once the the process of learning is
enjoyable well you don't care so much am
i making progress you're not measuring
yourself against something i didn't
achieve that forget it you're enjoying
the language you're enjoying the songs
you're enjoying this you have this sense
of wow i listened to this i didn't
understand it three months ago but now i
understand it and i know from experience
and you have to take my word for it if
you continue to expose yourself to the
language listening and reading the brain
is going to do a lot of it by itself
like we can in next week over the next
few weeks i'll talk about talk to you
about things that you can do to help
your brain along but the brain is going
to learn as long as you keep
enjoying the language
that's good very good
all right last question
how do you avoid translating into your
own language you can't
at least initially
but again because the whole process is
one of the brain getting used to the
language
if you do this naturally subconsciously
as pyotr says in in warsaw there
gradually the brain will start
seeing the text in the target language
as meaning
directly it won't need to translate but
it's a gradual process initially you're
translating almost all of it and then
your
certain phrases now automatically have
meaning in the target language and then
this just becomes a larger and larger
percentage of of what you're dealing
with so again uh i i think i did videos
about being patient don't get impatient
you know i'm still translating you're
still trying to say keep going and
you'll translate less and less and more
of it will be instant meaning in the
target language
all right
okay we went beyond the two minutes i
think but there you go there's a lot of
questions a lot of questions i'm gonna
talk a little bit longer so
just to finish off here keep sending
your questions in once a week i answer
questions and i'll do another video
where i will talk about my experiences
and and
some of the things that i'm discovering
on the 90 day challenge